in the late 2010s Elon Musk realized
something terrifying Larry Page and I
used to be close friends and I would
stay at his house in Palo Alto and I
would talk to him later tonight about AI
safety and at least my perception was
that Larry was not taking AI safety
seriously enough what did he say about
it he really seemed to be what it once
once sort of digital super intelligence
basically digital God if you will as
soon as possible um he wanted that yes
he's made many public statements over
the years uh that the whole goal of
Google is what's called AGI artificial
general intelligence or artificial super
intelligence you know and I agree with
him that there's great potential for
good but there's also potential for bad
and so if if you've got some radical new
technology you want to try to take a set
of actions that maximize probably it
will do good a minimize probably will do
bad things yes it can't just be helpful
either let's just go you know barreling
forward and you know hope for the best
and then at one point uh I said well
what about you know we're going to make
sure Humanity's okay here um
and and and they called me a speciesist
did he use that
term yes and there were Witnesses I
wasn't the only one there when you
called me a speciesist and so I was like
okay that's it yes I'm a specious okay
you got me
what are you
I'm fully auspicious um
um so
um that was the last straw hey I one of
the biggest potential threats to
humanity was being monopolized by one
single company Google which is headed by
this guy who isn't a specious at the
time Google owned three quarters of all
the AI Talent on the planet and no one
was even trying to compete with them in
elon's eyes AI could be more dangerous
than nuclear warheads so if we continue
down this path Larry Page the guy that
clearly doesn't value Humanity may end
up being the only ones in possession of
these weapons of mass destruction and
that was the final straw for Elon at the
time at Google had a quite Deep Mind and
so Google and deepmind together had
about three quarters of all the AI
talents in the world they obviously had
a trans amount of money and more
computers than anyone else so I'm like
okay we're about unipolar world here
where there's just one one company that
has close to Monopoly on anti-talent and
and computers like so scaled Computing
and the person who's in charge doesn't
seem to care about safety this is not
good so Elon brought together some of
the top people in the world of AI and
startups to create open AI Elon wanted
open AI to be the complete opposite of
Google's open AI would be open source a
non-profit that is fully open because
Google was closed for profit so that's
why the open and open AI refers to open
source you know transparency so people
know what's going on yes open AI was
founded as a non-profit and you know
there are some very influential people
at the creation of openai who basically
decided or had the feeling that you know
with the speed of AI once we're going to
hit AGI which is artificial general AI
which is you know an AI that could do
everything or anything that a human can
do once we had hit that point it would
create a massive shift in society that
we're not prepared for this is lior
Sinclair by the way he's an AI
researcher and the founder of
alphasigno.ai the biggest AI research
newsletter the initial idea of open AI
was to create a non-profit that would
research and kind of Safeguard the
progress of AI and so you know Elon Musk
was in there son maltman and you know
some other famous AI researchers and so
it started like that and everything was
good and at the beginning it got around
like a one billion dollar funding from
you know famous investors from the
readoffman Jessica Livingston and Peter
Thiel which for me was very interesting
because I don't think that those people
are known especially to do you know big
non-profit donations so right when I
heard that my first reaction was like oh
that's weird why would they give so much
money to a non-profit open AI was
supposed to be different I'm normally in
favor of for-profit we don't want this
to be a sort of a profit maximizing a
demon from hell that's right that just
never stops right open air wasn't about
making money it was about ensuring that
Ai and Humanity were on the same side
well our goal is to advance digital
intelligence in a way that is most
likely to benefit Humanity as a whole
unconstrained by a need to generate
Financial return since our research is
free from Financial Obligations we can
better focus on a positive human impact
end quote
which is a very Noble sounding cause but
then on the turn of a dime everything
changed Elon harder weighs with them and
open AI wet from being an open source
non-profit to a closed Source for-profit
business today the overlords I opened AI
believe that they're the only ones that
are smart enough to determine Humanity's
future that they are the sole Arbiters
of what's right and wrong it's the
smartest creatures as far as you know on
this Earth are humans is our defining
characteristic yes we're obviously
weaker than say chimpanzees or less
agile but real smarter so now what
happens when something vastly smarter
than the smartest person and this may
end up completely destroying Humanity
but can you be more precise about what's
potentially dangerous and scary like
what could it do what specifically are
you worried about going with old sayings
the pen is mightier than the sword so if
you have a super intelligent AI that is
capable of writing uh incredibly well
and in a way that is very influential
you know convincing and then and and is
constantly figuring out what is more
convincing to people over time and then
enter social media for example Twitter
but also Facebook and others you know
and and potentially manipulates public
opinion in a way that is very bad how
would we even know so why would anyone
not be a specist be human-centered in
his thinking about technology like
what's the thinking there um I think
what he's trying to say is that if I
were to guess uh that he that all
Consciousness should be treated equally
and whether that is digital or
biological and you disagree I disagree
yeah
especially if the digital Consciousness
or whatever you want to call digital
intelligence decides to curtail the
biological intelligence right so you're
just building your own slave master and
why would you do that doesn't sound
great
and now Elon has declared all-out war
against open AI
stay dangerous subscribe for more and
this is the war between Elon Musk and
open AI
thank you
and by the way guys if you're like me
and you prefer having a super simple
minimalist wardrobe so you don't have to
stress about what to wear then you gotta
check out true classic I don't need to
tell you how hard it is to find a good
t-shirt oftentimes they're expensive
don't fit well the fabric doesn't feel
high quality but with true classic their
best selling T-shirts are super
affordable while having a super clean
simple fit while also being really
comfortable the chest fits well the
sleeves aren't too big or too small the
back of the neck hole is flush for your
skin so you can be comfortable while
looking your best I got a pack of their
white t-shirts and another pack of their
black ones but it's not just t-shirts
true classic is your One-Stop shop for
your entire wardrobe including joggers
outerwear and every kind of shirt type
you could want and for a limited time
you can upgrade your wardrobe with 25
off using the code Jake with the link
below that's 25 off with code Jake by
pausing the video and clicking the link
below thanks to True classic for
sponsoring this video
in open ai's defense they started out
with good intentions but there was a
problem money even with someone the
wealthiest businessman in the world
backing it open AI was struggling to
stay afloat financially you see training
AI isn't cheap you know running and
training AI is very costly costs a lot
of money uh you know we're talking you
know hundreds of thousand dollars per
day of training and so it left them in a
really bad situation and they needed
money to train those you know models so
open AI was a non-profit in an industry
where you needed billions just to get by
to give you an idea of just how much
money you need some estimates say that
chat gbt cost 700 000 a day to operates
a truly insane amount that might be a
little challenging for a non-profit to
handle so how could open AI ever help to
compete with Google and their endless
bank account while trying to stay as a
non-profit if something didn't change
soon open air would eventually have to
close its doors by 2018 the non-profit
started trying to make that shift they
were thinking about going for profits
but Elon wasn't into it but let's keep
that aside Elon Musk joined and then
somewhere in around 2018 something big
happened and what happened 2018 is that
they released the first paper on large
language models and that was the initial
version that would you know later become
child GPT that was in 2018 and so 2018
was a transformative year for openai
because from the beginning to 2018 they
were working on you know music
generation they're working on AI for
video games such as Starcraft and other
games but what happened in 2018 is they
did that shift going to large language
models and also Elon Musk decided to
step out of openai and so it left open
AI in a tough position because running
and training AI is very costly costs a
lot of money you know we're talking
hundreds of thousand dollars per day of
training and so it left in a really bad
situation and they needed money to train
those you know models and back in the
daisy the most promised a billion
dollars you know after he said he
stepped out they had to find their money
elsewhere and that's where Microsoft
came in and they invested that one
billion dollar back in 2018 so 2018 is a
crazy year for opinion and I think it
sets the tone for everything to happen
you know up to now this caused a lot of
tension between Elon and the rest of the
open AI board Elon did not want to stray
from their original ideals Elon even
tried to take over the company to run
things his way allegedly but the other
co-founders wouldn't budge so Elon left
you know back in the days it was clear
that it would be for-profit what I think
could have happened maybe is that openai
had the money problem early and said you
know if we were to continue doing our
research in AI we're going to have we're
going to need more money and to do that
we might need to create a paid product
or switch from non-profit to for-profit
at that point I think Elon Musk must
have said you know I'm not in for that
I'm out that was in 2018 and when he
left Elon took the one billion dollar
donation he promised to the company with
them Elon told the press that it was a
conflict of interest because he was
working on self-dropping cars that used
AI at Tesla but the truth was Elon was
biting his tongue and now that Elon was
out of the way open AI was free to do as
they pleased but now they faced another
other big problem now open AI was short
a billion dollars back in the days you
almost promised a billion dollars and
you know after he said he stepped out
they had to find the money elsewhere
losing Elon and his billions was a huge
blow to the already struggling
non-profits so they went for profits and
to soften the blow open AI said they
would Implement a cap profit system in
which the original investors could only
receive a measly 100x their Investments
I know what a shame open AI promised
that going for profit wouldn't change
things at all but they lied because
practically as soon as they went for
profits they got right in bed with
Microsoft hi I'm here with Sam Altman
CEO of open AI today we are very excited
to announce a strategic partnership with
open AI Microsoft and open AI announced
a multi-year partnership that included a
convenient a billion dollar investment
from Microsoft and now what started out
as a non-profit to fight against Google
had become a de facto arm of Microsoft
open AI also threw away the whole open
source thing as well you have to
understand AI is a no print Source world
we all help each other everything is
transparent and that one of the things
that you know people are a bit mad about
for opinion is the everything is closed
source to their point of view you it's
normal it is close to us because it's a
lot of power then you just don't want to
release that power all of a sudden open
a I thought it was too dangerous to keep
everything transparent they started
withholding information and not letting
the public use their AI models suddenly
no one really knew what open AI was
doing behind closed doors just like
Google but they had a really good
argument for closing things off AI was
too powerful after all we can't just let
all this power fall into the wrong hands
by making it openly available since it's
open source it can be modified and
that's where the problem comes in the
problem comes in when you are giving
power that is you know adjustable to
your needs so now you have new cyber
security not cyber security researchers
but more like hackers that can now use
it to improve their code or to fight
vulnerabilities on their website and who
better to safeguard AI than us I mean
we're obviously the smartest most moral
people in the room so with the money in
hand and the Black Box sealed open AI
catapulted to where it is today as one
of the most powerful and influential
companies in America worth tens of
billions of dollars but to be for the
door turns at open AI probably really do
believe that they're doing the right
thing
I think one of the most interesting
facts about opinion is that cell maltman
does not have any share in the company
so I know that yeah it's kind of crazy
he's the CEO and he's not you know
you're not making any money off of neon
I guess it's just like reputational and
also I'm sure he's giving himself a good
salary but he's not he doesn't have any
equity in open AI so I'm not sure about
the other co-founders like Helia and and
Greg but for some moment I know he's
like he has no equity in okay makes
sense I didn't know that if that's the
case then you can pretty much assume
that he actually really does believe in
their mission and everything yeah yeah
but it's very interesting because it's
it's there's a lot of mystery around
this because you have to think about
this Sam Altman is a startup veteran
okay he he was running while combinator
some Altman was a very Israel a very
respected you know person in the Silicon
Valley and everything is Silicon Valley
screams for-profit capitalism right and
so you have to you have to ask yourself
why did he drop everything he had one of
the best jobs in the world and you know
it wasn't an easy way to become a
billionaire why did he drop everything
to stop open AI also another co-founder
of openai was you know Greg Brockman I
think and he was you know at stripe
which is definitely for-profit so you
know and the third person was Ilya which
yeah I believe he he maybe have you know
a higher purpose because he's like you
know an AI researcher with no you know
kind of business or startup or
capitalistic motive and on top of that
opening AI is making an effort to
safeguard it so what's cool at open AI
is that even though they are the ones
who are pushing uh the boundaries
they're also the ones safe supporting it
and that's super interesting I I don't
see any company doing that so open AI
will release charge GPT and then right
after that they'll release a report
saying what jobs will be impacted by it
and that's I feel like it's very
honorable it's a it's a good thing
they're doing they're also partnering up
with independent research lab to make
sure that chai GPT and GPT are you know
cannot run off by themselves and you
know clone themselves and and just be
independent so they're doing a lot of
things to safeguard it but as they say
the road to hell is paid with good
intentions and with open AI having more
power and influence than ever before
while actively trading their AI to lie
Elon Musk decided it was time to sound
the alarm one last time
[Music]
foreign
T launches in November 2022 a month
later Elon learns that open AI has been
accessing Twitter's data to train his AI
so he cuts off their access in March he
tweeted this meme
and then in early April Elon Musk and
others called for a six-month pause in
AI research but this was more of a
symbolic move to get eyeballs Elon knew
that there was absolutely no chance apos
would actually happen look I think is it
pause realistic it's not is it a symbol
that might be you know about the pause
and so it's an it's an important symbol
I think to the world into the world of
AI that you know it's kind of an alarm
more than I don't think it's it's
realistic I don't think it will be
implemented it's just impossible to
implement because even if a research lab
pauses you know another just could
continue for another country you know
how do you even decide who's pausing
who's not puzzling so it's about it's
impossible to decide that but I think
it's an important alarm it's an
important red flag that things are going
too fast and we need to slow it down a
little bit or think about the
repercussions of all of that
um but I'm not sure it's realistic at
this point Elon came to the conclusion
that there was obviously only one thing
left to do he had to go toe-to-toe with
a monster he helped create so in late
April Elon being the marketing as he is
sits down with Tucker Carlson to declare
a war Microsoft has a very strong say if
not directly controls open AI at this
point so you really have an open-ended
Microsoft situation and then a Google
deepmind uh the other two sort of
heavyweights in this Arena so it seems
like the world needs a third option yes
I think I will create a third option I'm
worried about the fact that uh it's been
it's being trained to be politically
correct which is simply another way of
of being on Truth saying untruthful
things yes so that's that's a bad sign
there's certainly a path to AI dystopia
is to train an AI to be deceptive so
yeah I'm going to start something which
I know you call truth gbt or a maximum
truth-seeking AI that tries to
understand the nature of the universe
and I think this might be the best path
to Safety in the sense that an AI that
cares about understanding the universe
is unlikely to annihilate humans because
we are an interesting part of the
universe hopefully Eli AI company is
called x.ai and he made sure that he was
the only person in charge by listening
himself as a sole director of the
company Elon made it clear that he'll do
whatever it takes to go toe-to-toe with
open Ai and Google and whichever company
comes out on top will be in control of
Humanity's future but elon's got some
steep competition ahead of him when
Microsoft putting another 10 billion
dollars into open AI however the real
money and power might not just be with
the actual AI models from open AI or
Google or even elon's company the real
power will be in the data and I think
this is before the world away I will go
is that you know AI is very open source
so everybody has the same models or
almost the same and the big difference
is going to be the data the big
difference is going to be you know I
trained on a data set you can't train on
I have the deal with Reddit to train my
GPT on all of Reddit and if you do
they're going to sue you because we have
an exclusive deal so there's a lot of
you know repercussions and a lot of I
think you know there's a lot of secret
Partnerships and deals that are going to
happen in the next 12 20 50 years with
AI because the power is not the model
the power is not the AI the powers and
the data that's fascinating I didn't
think about that because you know data
is already so valuable these days but
now it's going to become more valuable
yeah exactly data is super valuable and
you know there's right now you know in
the last few months there's a lot of
controversies regarding stable diffusion
and you know and mid journey and all
these generative AI for art and you know
a lot of people are saying yeah they you
know they're they're ripping off artists
without their you know approval and they
train those models on that and we don't
have any laws to prevent that and you
know it's very hard to say was that
illegal nobody knows but you know maybe
what's going to happen is that we're
going to see a huge shift in the world
of startups where startups are going to
have their monetization and and business
plan around the data they can sell
instead of what the product does so
maybe the product is free maybe the
product you know is is just attracting
people to train data on and so that's
that's going to be a big shift that that
is going to happen in the next 10 years
but fear not because it's not all doom
and gloom like every Revolution before
it the AI Revolution will make a select
view very very wealthy so I decided to
get lior's take on what opportunities he
sees in the space right now that you can
take advantage of being that he's neck
deep in the trenches every day well I
think to make money in the AR Revolution
[Music]
and we're gonna go over all of it in an
upcoming video so make sure you
subscribe and if you want to keep up
with AI also be sure to sign up for
Alpha signal leora's free AI newsletter
where he literally built his own AI
models to scour the internet and send a
weekly summary of the top research
papers repos and tweets happening right
now in the AI space straight into your
inbox this isn't a paid ad or anything
it's just really cool and it's read by
over 50 000 world-class researchers and
Engineers from Google open AI Amazon
Facebook and more and you can sign up
for free by clicking the square on the
screen stay dangerous and we'll see you
in the next one
foreign
[Music]